Evet
[Müzik]
hepinize Merhaba hoşgeldiniz değerli
katılımcılar değerli konuşmacılar Uzun
bir aradan sonra bu arada değerli Ökkeş
koşuda teşekkürlerimi sunuyorum hem
direktörlük anlamında
geçen sene itibariyle tanışmıştık Biz
süreçte teksin ve Mahallesi ile ilgili
çalışmalarda konuşmacı olarak daha
doğrusu sunumla ilgili olarak bulmuştum
Mesleğimi yapmaktan gurur ve onur
duyuyorum Burada şimdi sadece mesleğimle
ilgili olarak değil Evet Gaziantep'in
ilk çocuk spikerlerin dedim yaklaşık 12
yaşında sürmeye başladım ve sekiz
yaşındayken abartmadan söylüyorum
mikrofon elimdeydi
yaptıktan sonraki dönem itibariyle 16
yaş itibari artık bu ha Birlik
arkasından haber spiker o ulusal genel
ve ulusal kanalların birçoğunda program
yapımcılığı binin üzerinde olmuştur
herhalde şu anda
Yani katılımcılar
Bizi biz yapan değerler vardır aslında
biz Önce kendimize güvenmeliyiz ne
medyadan başlarken medyanın zorluklarını
hepimiz şahidiz görmüşsünüzdür Sizlerde
aynı şekilde
farkındasınızdır
medya dördüncü güç olarak
isimlendiriliyor ama maalesef ki değer
bakımından
yerlerde
paneli ile birlikte daha da
farklılaşmaya başladı yeni dönem Bütün
sıkıntıları da beraberinde getirdi
online eğitimler olmayan programlar
yapısal döngü hepside çok rahat olarak
karşılaşıyoruz
çok değerli başkanımız dikkat Bey
bahsetti Özellikle sosyal medya üzerinde
de lütfen her şeye inanmayın çünkü
sosyal medyanın gücü inanılmaz derecede
yüksek Neden biliyor musunuz bir
devletin kurulumuna sahne olabilirsiniz
aynı Amerika Birleşik Devletleri
başkanın Twitter'dan yapmak
istedikleriyle birlikte
sosyal medya bütün verilerinizin
depolandığı kurgulandığı Siz istemeseniz
dahi yapıldığı bir oluşum ne yemek
yediğinizden ne giyse giydiğinizden Ama
özellikle Haberlere dikkat çekmek
istiyorum bakın haberler
Benim için vazgeçilmez bir unsurdur her
zaman program kapanışında düşünün
söyledim haber hayattır hayatta haberdir
Siz bütün bilgileri bir ekrana bakarak
olduğunu düşünürsünüz arka planda
yaşanan gerçekler ve sizlere hazır bu
süreç içerisinde
onların bütün meşakkatleri uygun bir
şekilde vermemiz gerekiyor Haberlere
başladım an itibariyle tamamen o
dünyadan kopmuş un dur haberin içeriğine
göre yön vermeye başlamışsındır bir
cinayet haberi sesi oradayım
gözlemliyorum bakıyorum neler yaşanmış
bir trafik kazası İsa ki şehitlerimiz
var Rabbim inşallah Onların mekanlarını
cennet eylesin orada olmuş olsaydın
objektif olarak bakmak gerekiyor oradaki
görüntüleri sizlere yansıtma lazım haber
dedi çok farklı şekildedir insanları
nasıl algılamasını isterseniz öyle
kesersiniz içersiniz Konuşurken de aynı
şekilde biz bazen
programa başladığımız da
özellikle
insanlara sorularla yönlendirmeye
çalışırız
içimdekini dışa vurmasını sağlarız
Çapraz bu mantığı ile hareket etmesini
sağlarız medyanın gücü işte burada
çıkıyor
Sizin söylemek istemediklerimizi dahi
size sorarak sizin ağzınızdan alarak
karşıya satma pazarlama taktiğidir
aracılık anlamında konuşuyorum diğer
unsurlarla Maalesef ki Türkiye'de
magazin haberciliği çok daha fazlasıyla
ön plana çıkmaya başladı Çim ne yedi
kiminle 7 akşam ne yapıyordu
biz artık bunlardan kurtulmamız
gerekiyor Türkiye'nin haber
kirliliğinden sıyrılması gerekiyor
işimi zevk alarak yapıyorum Hobi olarak
görmüyorum bu işi Eğer istediğiniz gibi
bi ruhunuzla talebinizle
yansıtabilirsiniz Ancak o şekilde
ulaşabilirsiniz Size de en büyük
tavsiyem önce kendiniz bu kendinize
güvenmeniz Çünkü insan kendine
güvenmediği Zaman ne bu sahneye
gelebilir ne rahatça oturabilir Evet
sizinle konuşabilir bir doğru olanı
yapmak isterseniz
karşımızdakini dinlemek zorundasınız
bizim Maalesef ki medyada
karşılaştığımız en büyük sorunlardan bir
tanesi dinlemesini bilmeden konuşmaya
çalışmak Biz bunları ne zaman doğru yola
sokarsak o şekilde daha da ileriye doğru
gideceğimize düşünüyoruz hesaplar çok
basit bir şekilde kapanabilir
insanlar kameralara Aşina olmayabilir
değerli konuşmacılar ımızı da bu açıdan
lütfen takdir ettiğimi de belirtmek
istiyorum ağzınıza yüreğinize gönlünüze
sağlık Çünkü hiç kimsenin başaramadığı
bir şey yapıyorsunuz insanlara fikrinize
paylaşıyorsunuz işte teksin platform
anlamında dünyaya sesini duyulmasını
sağlayan ve Bu sebepten de dünyaya
geçişini sağlayacak olan oluşun
gençlerin desteklenmesiyle olur Ve bu da
yine medyayla sosyal medya üzerinden şu
anda bizi izleyen izleyicilerimiz burada
kırıklıklarını Belki çok farklı şekilde
algılayacak var Ama şu var biz dünyanın
tamamen güç noktasının sosyal medya
olduğunu idrak etmemiz gerekiyor ama
temiz sosyal medya ne demek istediğimizi
yeni şekilde algılayacak bizi rahat bir
şekilde insanları anlatılabilecek doğru
dürüst ve güvenilir habercilik anlamında
vurgulanması gerekiyor Bu değerli
katılımcılar
mesleğe ilk başladığım yıllarda
çocukluğunu vermiş olduğu heyecanla çok
Hatalar yaptım Belki sonunda belki
insanlara karşı hitap etti Fakat zaman
içerisinde gelişiyor zaman içerisinde
hatalarınızı da görev bu
hatalardan ders alamıyorsanız işte o
zaman kritik noktaya doğru gidiyorsunuz
ben bir çok çok uluslarası programlarda
görev aldım ve aynı şekilde kendi
kendimin haricinde birçok vilayette de
Kendi kendimden bahsetmeyi isterseniz
sunumlara gidiyorum ve bu benim için
ayrı bir odun noktasıdır insanları
bilgilendirme biliyorsanız onlara
Gözlerinizin içine baktığında Ben
buradayım Ve siz Kendi kendinize
biliyorsunuz dinliyorsunuz sizi size
anlatmak çok farklı tiyatro Yollarına
başladığımda
1989 yılların daydı iki şehir
tiyatrosu'nun olduğu dönemlerde is
pressed sinemasının hatırlayanlar olduğu
için söyleyebilirim tiyatro iç çıktığı
dönemler o yıllardı heyecanlı sahneye
çıkıyorum Kor
çok değerli hitap etmeye çalışıyorum
çünkü ilk yani tiyatro dediğim olarak
ilk sunum olarak farklı ama Şuradaki
insanlara baktığımız zaman ben
gözlerinin benim üzerinde olduğunda
heyecan bir titreme geliyor bu fakat
sonra diyorum ki işi profesyonel içtikçe
daha da farklılaşıyor iyi ki o heyecan
var diyorum İyi ki o heyecan benimle
birlikte oldu çünkü o heyecanla birlikte
ben o insanlara daha iyi şekilde sesli
edebilmenin yolunu öğrendim
biz bunları Gaziantep'te iç çıkıyor
doğru toplamaya çalıştık başarı elde
ettik birçok oyunda oynadım yani 100'ün
üzerinde oyun öğretmenlik yaptım hala
yapıyorum Fırsat buldukça çok zaman
bulamıyorum bu tür konularla ilgili ama
biliyorum ki insanı insana insanla
anlatan sanat ikili ilişkilerdeki
burunlusu da gözünü almaktadır
Allah bizi bize anlatmayan insanlar
yüzünden zorluklar yaşıyoruz
bizim en büyük dileğimiz Biz insanlarla
konuşabilmek konuşa bilmemiz için de bu
varlıklarını bizi anlatmaları gerekiyor
Biz buradayız dmlere gerekiyor işte ben
başlığı bu şekilde gönderdim önce
kendinize güveneceksin iz ki
karşınızdaki insanlara neler söylemek
istediklerinizi doğru bir şekilde
anlatacaksınız yanlış her kimine göre
ama bilginin hiçbir zaman yanlış olacağı
ya Daha fazlası öğrenmesiyle Yerden Yere
Vur olamayacağı aşikârdır
Biraz önce hatalardan bahsettim iş
deneyimleri ile ilgili çok hatalar
yapabilirsiniz Ama siz aynaya
baktığınızda
konuştuğunuzda kendinizle barışık sanız
İşte o zaman size hiç kimse yıldıramaz
hangi işte olursanız olun
başarıya odaklanacak sınız bu ve Odak
noktası sizi bir yerden alıp götürecek
hayatın her evresinde zorluklarla
geldiniz Kimimiz Belki o çocukluk
yıllarında çocuklarla beraber
dolaşıyordu o Üstü başı kıyafetleri
yırtık bir şekildeydi ama azminden
vazgeçmedi okudu Okumakla yetinmedi
okuduğunu paylaştı
bizim en büyük sorunumuz
paylaşmayı bilmemek bak ha
tırnaklarımıza Benim kendi çocukluğumun
en büyük hatıralarından bir tanesi de
babamın amcasının oğlu bunun ışığında
ders altında çalışırdı şu an ülkeleri
profesörlerinden
zorluklar karşısında yılmamak gerekiyor
içinizdeki Güven noktasını dışarıya
atmanız gerekiyor ve biz tarihini unutan
bir millet olduğumuz için geçmişteki
hatıratlar bu sağlayarak yol almamız Ve
bunu yaparken de medyanın ve sosyal
medyanın gücünü değini şekilde
aktarmamız gerekiyor Hani diyoruz ya bir
zaman olduktan sonra her şey değişti
tepsinin bu konuşmasının ana teması da
her şey değişti Siz her şeyi değiştirmek
istiyorsanız eğer
Kendinizden başlayın lütfen
başkalarına ders vereceğim diye onun
karşısına geçip Ben her şeyi biliyorum
demeyin A 45 yaşındayım bu zamana kadar
kimseye öyle bir şey söylemedim demem de
ilk önce dinleyeceğim hataları varsa ona
göre yönlendireceğim ve benim bütün
ekibimde kanallarla ilgili olarak
konuşuyorum şu an çalışma profil
içerisindeki olanlarla değil
sistemli ve kurallı şekilde hareket
etmek zorundadır asla ve asla izleyici
ve dinleyici saygısız bu içinde
bulunmasına müsaade etmedim etmem dedi
yorgunsam radyoya kesinlikle çıkmam
Çünkü benden aldığı o sesini şekilde
yansıtması gerekiyor ve o haliyle
dinleye bilmesi gerekiyor ama maalesef
günümüzde o kadar çok az tür Yani saçma
konularla ilgili şeyler izlenmeye
başlıyor ki kültürel anlamda bir şeyler
vermeye başladığınız anda kimsesiz
izlemiyor reklam ortalaması şu anda genç
kuşak için söylüyorum 4 saniyede
Algıladı algıladı algılamadığı sizi
iştir yiyorlar ve tamamen ani
zafiyetleri Ziya sosyal medya Artık
tamamen diğer sayfalarda uyuyorlardı
mesele sağlıyorlar bu nedenle Biz algiyi
yönetir sackpack medyadaki değişimi yeni
rolleriyle birlikte adapte edebilirsek
başarı bizim için kaçınılmaz olacaktır
sosyal medyanın gücünü iyi yönetemiyor
sanız pazarla yapmıyorsanız sa bu ve
sadece isimler üzerinden giderek
yaklaşık 25 milyon takipçisi olan 50
milyon takipçi olan ama içerik anlamında
boş kitlelere buluşursak O da bizim
atamız var burada kendimize neslimize
yönlendirme mizin en büyük hataları
Bunlar lütfen
kentimizi tanıyalım
kendimizi bilelim
insanlarımıza sosyal medya üzerinden
yayınlar yapıyorsa ki hala da yapıyorum
şehrin sesi ile ilgili Başkanlar
Konuşuyor ile ilgili olarak Çünkü
insanlara ulaşmak istiyorum doğruları
onlarla Nasıl paylaşabilirim nasıl
anlatabilirim derdindeyiz Siz kendinizi
bunu dert edinirseniz ki o zaman kapılar
sizin için sonuna kadar açılır her şey
değişir o hoş geldiniz tekrar aramıza
bizlerle birlikte olduğunuz için
teşekkür ederiz Ama bu güvenmeden o
içinizdeki duyguları taşımadan da
yaşamadan gitmeyin Lütfen buradan önce
kendinize güvenin görüşmek üzere
hoşçakalın